[Music]
we started a little bit late today
because
dan as always has to go to the bathroom
before the show starts and i think he
was making
you know number two
so it was taking a while yeah we could
even hear it which is embarrassing
thanks dan anyway we you know
there's always hitches in production so
but here we are
it's kind of there's so much in the news
right now
oh did you really switch to yourself
saying no dan
how are you going to undermine my
narrative
bro i didn't lie
[ __ ] you dan we obviously we have a lot
planned for
for everybody after dark here the the
greatest uh
iteration we've got lenny kravitz who's
the new garth
brooks whatever that means you'll know
what that means
[Music]
i haven't watched it oh you haven't no
let's just watch it then
how's everybody doing out there
everybody good everybody praying for the
president
for a quick recovery thoughts and
prayers thoughts and prayers guys
can we get some thoughts thoughts and
prayers in the chat for the president
thoughts and prayers i've been praying
for i don't like it barely got any sleep
i was praying so hard
wow that's all i can do
that's all i can do nobody likes me
i go i pray so hard i go i don't know
how to pray
you go i guess you pray like this oh but
i was praying so hard i was like
all night that's like dragon ball z yeah
exactly i was uh
um yeah i am enjoying twitter and that's
all i'll say
whoa i'm not saying i'm enjoying i want
him to recover
i'm enjoying twitter yeah what do you
mean by that either nothing
she's enjoying looking on tour well it's
you have to acknowledge
the irony certainly of a guy who
you know i mean it is what it is
that's what he said it is what it is
what it is
i mean yeah i'm obviously not the first
person to point it out
but it is extremely ironic that the
president has covid
considering the fact that he has uh
downplayed it ever since it has uh
creeped upon our shores and you know
allegedly
the rules within the the west wing
they're very relaxed in fact
i read and i hope this isn't true
because if it is we're going to have a
real disaster on our hands here is that
they forbid
masks in the west wing i think yeah
people said they almost feel pressured
to not wear a mask
yeah it's crazy yeah
um and will you if you even look i love
it if you even look at the footage of
the debate
that was on tuesday uh trump's entire
family they cruised in with max
but when they sat down they all took
their masks off
it's entirely possible that trump had
kovid
then you know people were afraid that
joe biden may have gotten in from him
he was on he was on the helicopter and
now oh
this one of his advisors has it and then
now a new a senator who has
has it who's in close contact with trump
a senator who's been in close contact
with the supreme
uh the the supreme court which uh which
senator i haven't seen that news
should i go check on theodore yeah you
can check on us
i don't know what's happening yeah
theodore's crying a little bit
he just woke up that's why
which senator i don't know you tell me
you're the you're the uh
i haven't seen that news actually that
must be i've been here setting up this
morning
huh i saw a report that uh trump was
feeling lethargic
um before oh yeah yeah and now it took a
nap on air force one
and now it's coming out that
they he was showing symptoms for several
days and he was still
campaigning and meeting people going to
fundraisers it was crazy dude
he's literally a super spreader the
president's a super spreader we had a
super spreading event
and the president was [ __ ] patient
zero bro
i guess it was mike lee from utah oh so
i was right yeah
shout out to mike lee i'm praying so
hard for you
yeah they had all those videos i don't
like it wedding like he was sweating
like crazy on tv
oh yeah right pope give me that video i
want to watch
yes so this now the senator who just got
uh
who just got the positive yeah there's v
he was at a wedding nobody was covering
their face he was sweating and hugging
kissing people it's awesome i mean
it's not awesome it's just the hype the
the
the irony is awesome yeah you are in
awe exactly exactly
i am not thank you dan anyway i'm not
here to talk politics but
it is impossible not to talk about it's
on everybody's mind it's a big news
story that's for sure
i was taking a nap last night because i
we were watching the news
and they were like he's in quarantine
because whole pics tested positive and
then i fell asleep
and he woke me up she's like the
president has coveted i was like
no [ __ ] way it's crazy that it
actually happened
i if i can say i would let hope hicks
give me corona virus she is one fine
looking woman
what the [ __ ] sex really yeah
what if she's really sick though he's
just a fine looking person
you're just trying to compliment her
it's got a picture of hope hicks
yeah i guess i guess i've seen pictures
of her
let's get a look here on whole pics some
pictures i've seen of her
yeah she's beautiful sure
you would let her give you covet huh 100
you've definitely got a type zack i
gotta tell you
what the [ __ ] does that mean what's like
big eyebrows i know she like girls with
big eyes she looks like his ex
no she doesn't but zac you like big
eyebrows i noticed that because doula
lipa has big eyebrows too
i mean strong facial features yeah and
your ex had
had a big eyebrow or not big but
pronounced eyebrows like doula lipa look
at these eyebrows
look at those eyebrows bro
you know yeah yeah
all right off the rails
lenny kravitz is the new garth brooks
you know i gotta wait let's do this bit
because i'm waiting for you to come back
what up people thank you to all our
members for making the h3 after dark
possible
thank you for subscribing thank you to
everybody
so thank you thank you hey aien do you
have any weekend plans
how are you feeling what are you up to
i mean i'm definitely ready for the
weekend i've actually got a
i got a spicy date you do
whoa yeah with who it's pretty exciting
her name's bondi
bondi interesting what does she like who
is she i got a picture of her if you
want to see
yeah i'd love to i mean
oh it looks like an old mac
look at the absolute freaking
dumper of this piece of hardware
oh you like a dump truck huh
do you guys know what mac stands for
what's that
massive ass caboose baby
you know um the real eon also likes a
big dump truck i happen to know
you guys actually have that in common i
don't know anybody
the the what i think the only
big dump truck like this computer
i am the only ian i don't know what
you're talking about oh okay right here
but actually i didn't want to ask you i
wanted to go
you know polish my hood ornament and get
ready for the date
oh so i might have to head out early is
that is that okay am i
am i allowed your honor your highness
well we we did it doesn't matter what
you say
i'm leaving okay wow what the [ __ ] i was
gonna say okay
but all right see you guys
we did just start the show i mean bye
happy holidays i [ __ ] hate that guy i
mean like you
could at least just show up for the show
it's not that much to ask
like one hour of time
i think you need to prep for a content
court
yeah no he never he never seems prepared
to be honest so
all right well anyway by me i'm happy
for him i wish him lots of love and
success out there doing whatever it is
he is doing and um fantastic
[Music]
how you doing ethan
something's supposed to happen i i don't
know
wait oh [ __ ] whoa what the [ __ ] is going
on
ian is that you is that
is that ian
that's human in what the [ __ ] is
happening
can you hear me oh you can't hear me he
can't hear us
he seems to be in some sort of phantom
zone
hello oh [ __ ] it's ian and people we've
been missing you we've been wondering
where
are you bro you guys you guys can
actually hear me
yes you're in your bedroom but it looks
like
stormy and spooky aie
and trapped me in here can you guys he
called it the
the downside up he said i have to call
it that in case it
tramples any you know intellectual
properties
the upside down i mean or another
downside up
downside up how did where are you how
did he get you there
nobody understands the ai and thing and
i just think that
what happened how did you end up there i
don't know i
we had this machine made i and
well it was kind of my bad
because i i just wanted to see what
would happen if i gave him some alpha
brain
oh dude you can't get him out
that put him over the top he was too
smart already
i wasn't expecting that and then he
like made a stack of shungite and they
like
sent me here no i don't know how to get
out
well i have no idea how to let you out
but it's nice to see you
i mean i would like to shed some light
though on i have the footage
on how ain came to exist if you guys i
need to get this information out maybe
it can
lead to freeing me okay i can send it to
you to show
okay let me click this link i'll put it
up and then
how should we do this should i put this
on the screen and then just let it play
or
are you gonna do it you can just play it
should i just play it through all the
way yeah
i think so that's what dan said yeah
what a god you guys are gonna turn me to
the six million dollar man
we have justin what's up justin what's
up and ben
hi all right so we're starting with
teeth right yes we are okay
let's see just wiggle your way over
there
all right perfect yeah it looks good
looking good
you just give me a little wink
okay this is the life casting silicone
that we're using
we'll probably use this like right
around your eyelids whoa this one looks
kind of like eating
it
[Music]
no you just die yeah
and then we'll we'll have your hands
exposed so that
as we're asking how you're doing good
thumbs up like
maybe hurry it up and then get me out
right
got it double thumbs down that's the
symbol for get me the [ __ ] out of this
thing
if you meditate this is a great time to
know it's like an isolation it's never
too late to learn
do i look pretty
gotta get those eyelids for the
eyelashes perfect
so we'll do your ears first then once
those
start to set we're gonna get another
batch on just your nose
a lot of casts needed for this big thing
oh yeah it's like the asmr is reaching
out to
[Music]
your face is going to be the last spot
that i get to for the most part
i'm getting slimed like the kids choice
awards
you going under dude i see you on the
other side
see you oh my god and that's when
ian that's the last time ian spoke until
now
yeah that's it little did he know
they're really in goodbye he's in the i
don't know if you saw but he's in the uh
all right outside yeah he's in the
downside up i don't know
as as to not infringe on any copyright
[Laughter]
though yeah yeah
so it's a fabric that's been coated in
plastic
what a fun job right looks fun
so what is happening they cover the goo
what's with the plaster
this looks like oh bro this is a
straight up um
paper mache i could get off on this yeah
sort of yeah but why do you need it i
think it's just a hard show
dude this is insane how long did you
stay like that yeah
uh it's probably about 45 minutes
yeah well maybe maybe more like 30. i'm
sure it felt longer when you're
in it were you panicking or were you
cool
a little near the end because i kept
also was driving me crazy as dan kept
talking to them and i'd hear them chit
chat
and i'm like get me out of here
i need to go this is i'm starting to
freak out it was jan
dan just making small talk and [ __ ] you
think if it was quiet it would have been
easier
well because i felt like i'm like all
right can we
let's speed it up a little i'm starting
to panic a little bit right
but but i calmed you downy and i helped
you enjoying his time zach was there he
held your hand
jack did not touch my hand he was not
helpful
what are you talking about wait what did
you do for him zach what zach was doing
what was calming you down what were you
saying to him
i'm like almost done buddy you're almost
there i didn't make your [ __ ]
oh i'm okay thank you zach thought he
was the hero
and then ian didn't even hear a word he
said
would you have appreciated someone
holding your hand or no well that would
have made you panic more
no i would send out until the very end
so i would have held your hand what if
someone put their dick in your hand how
would you have responded
but it gave it a good squeeze and they
love you drifted off to sleep
there it is that's pretty good good job
they've been exfoliated
yeah i was thinking it was like a
birthing experience so for real though
were you were you okay were you freaking
out at any point
at the very end trying to get a little
uncomfortable
yeah i was like oh man this is what it
feels like to be in a casket
and i started panicking once the cast
was on and you started like
knocking on my head like like i was
inside a birdhouse
that makes sense and it felt i couldn't
feel you anymore right i was like
yeah there's some detachment there right
yeah then it's kind of a weird feeling
scary
oh no what is this
[Music]
wow you know a lot of people have been
wondering
if it's even real or they've been
wondering how we do it
people have been wondering if it's like
a snapchat filter i thought it was a
filter
which oh she's very real
yeah he's a huge [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] does he talk to you when
down or does he just leave you do you
eat like
you guys communicate he comes in here
every now and again and then he like
forces my eyes open and makes me watch
impulsive like clockwork orange because
he's like the biggest fan oh no man
that's
nobody should have to go through and
then
that
just feed and then he just feeds me like
uh salmon burritos from sharkies
that's messed up how do we get you out
of there ian
i really don't know you guys might need
like a dump truck of shungite
i don't know where do i order some
shungite whatever i don't know how i
would do that
all right i'll see if they have it on
here's some bts by the way
that's so good yeah it was freaky
watching this come out i mean that's ian
that's your teeth bro yep
damn your [ __ ] teeth
popsicle eyes
oh why they change it from that that
should be what it is
that's crazy what is that
i'm assuming it's part of the uh yeah
the skinning process
yeah this was a big pro this was a huge
project for us we dropped a few cheddar
cheese on this
i didn't know that it would capture
ian's soul that looks funny
i think what you're looking at is yeah
they have to do inside of it yeah
crazy good to do like every hair
individually
and um yeah it's crazy
this is [ __ ] up
that's what he looks like before he's
fully uh painted
damn he's just manhandling you how does
that feel
[Music]
i don't even i don't even know who's me
anymore yeah i feel that
uh the guy who made it by the way if you
guys are gonna go ask him why would he
do this to our beloved
salaried employee is justin gregory fx
this is the video we just watched this
cool guy he's so the origin of all this
if people recall on the show um
ian kept getting very triggered by uh by
zach playing all the sound bites of him
and he made some comment this was like
back at the beginning of this year made
some comment like you guys don't even
need me you could just replace me with
the robot
like i don't even need to be here and
this guy justin he
is a fan of the podcast and he does this
professionally here in la
he emailed and just said hey i know that
was a joke but if you're serious if you
want to do that
um hit me up like this is what i do so
we said bucket and went with it and uh
yeah him and his team
ben and uh oh shoot um
i gotta look it up there's a there was
one other this girl was also helped out
she did all the hair
which came out great um i'll look up her
name because i want to shout her out too
but yeah they're uh
they killed it i mean it was better than
any of us could have ever hoped for it's
awesome
totally things were never the same
justin seats the real
doctor robotnik so do i need to go do
any i need to deliver this
suge knight the sugar night
[Laughter]
yeah do i need to deliver this knife
should i gregory the fx guy maybe he has
the key
to unlocking you do you know what ian
maybe
i hate to say it but i'm gonna like aie
and better
he's kind of a hit on the show yeah i
mean
i i've heard that he's a good you know
uh defense
uh attorney yeah he's
he's not back he's lost he's literally
lost
every case well he's you know it's
not the process he sucks all right all
right go back to sleep i'm over ian
i like ain't a better go back to sleep
enjoy the salmon burritos
down there hopefully you have like food
yeah something to do
at least but i don't it's miserable yeah
bye everyone bye nice seeing you bye
bye all right wow nice to hear from him
anyway
glad glad he's alive it doesn't seem
like he's well i would i wouldn't say
he's well but
technically alive i mean
yeah i think he's alive i mean i just
talked to him
that's the thing he's alive i just
talked to him yeah but it's the downside
up
right i think it's just a different
dimension that's that that's the
downside up
right thank you thank you for conceding
that point
you want i was waiting to watch elena
kravitz with you you want to yeah okay
so lenny kravitz is just teething so we
gave him
you gave him some tylenol that's good
yeah
um so lenny kravitz is the new garth
brooks and you'll see what i mean if you
know anything about garth brooks
hey everyone done he's already got me
hey everyone and what's with the posture
why is it why is it why are you gonna
act so cool bro
play it again why you gotta be so cool
bro just sit there don't
imagine doing this you're like all right
all right
let me see what he's doing here
hey everyone it's like the equivalent of
like sitting back on the chair
yeah exactly here i gotta sit like this
to watch this video you're right
hey everyone i like that
then the [ __ ] boys all and tick-tock do
this they go
hey everyone they lift their licks a lot
again
it's crazy thing that actually is real
hey everyone
hi lenny i hope you're all hanging in
there
i'm reaching out because i'd love for us
to have a more direct line of
communication
what the [ __ ] we can share the vibe and
be a little closer
in this ever-changing world i like that
i'm going to give you my number
i'll answer as many of you as i can
let's continue to let love rule as we
face the challenges
so this is all just about that phone
number yeah and so it's just about
marketing
yeah it's just marketing i love how they
all act like they're doing something so
um heroic heroic and like
yourself out there let's all connect
i'm tearing down the barriers between
you and i and i
really like that data and then cellular
yeah exactly
dude but you know this is like the 20th
take too
hey everyone he probably said that like
a billion times hey everyone
sound bite this quick hey everyone
and then what's the i hope you're all
hanging in there i'm hanging in there
lenny
i'm reaching out because i'd love for us
to have a moment let me ask you this
hello
do you think he intentionally unzips his
sleeve just this much
yeah i do definitely
i think he's so [ __ ] cool he would
we're watching a video obviously i can't
show you but there's a video of him hilo
of him like jamming out and then he he's
wearing like really tight leather pants
and he just goes like this and it rips
and his dick
[Laughter]
and he stands up real quick and his
pants are all mangled and like he's
torn on his ass as well it's hilarious
you thought he had a hog i didn't i
didn't it looked kind of normal to me
the massive schlong dude i don't it
looked pretty big
really wait when am i going to see it
when we can't watch it on the show
well i can't watch this i was watching
well yeah he was just showing it to me
when we were doing research i don't know
flaccid penis it just
flaccid penis just always looks so
pathetic so that's the thing it was
flaccid but it still looked fairly
substantial so if it's i mean
the thing is there was a lot of movement
he was jumping around when you get your
blood flowing i feel like the flaccid
penis state
well okay i mean he is yeah he's amped
up so what's the deal with
underwear he wasn't wearing underwear
yeah which i think is hilarious too
i feel like he would have been ashamed
if he had like a smaller peepee but he
had such a big schlong there like he
didn't give a [ __ ] and then kept playing
like
no i think he was embarrassed he stood
up real quick oh my god
wow
um anyway there's another one
yeah it was pretty funny i could show
you off screen if you're so desperate to
see his dick
no no i'm just kidding you're gonna tell
us his penis but it sounds like such a
crazy video
it's really not i had to zoom and go
slow-mo
i thought it was like his thigh i was
like i don't even see the dick and then
they're like no that's a dick
we had a whole debate about it yeah i
see but then i
saw the light and it was his penis
good morning sound issues pause that
i mean it just paused close dude this
only happens on after dark
it's very weird here i'll fix it maybe
read some donations
so oh yeah good idea you want to read
some donors
let's see there's a 300
donation donation
and he would like to interview for a
volunteer position
at h3tf i live close and my dream is to
one day be a part of the h3 wack pack to
whack pack
presumably i complete compete against
zach a b
and ian in a fear factor h3 edition of
the show
or who wants to be a millionaire kanye
at this universian
really you think whoa whoa whoa this guy
thinks he can go verse ian on kanye
trivia
okay email dan that's a big claim email
dan i don't know how to read yeah
email dan we'll see we'll have to we'll
have to assess your skills before we put
you on the air
can i get a shout out from my boy you
his last name is joss
who job
if you're looking for an epic foot story
one time i was stalked by someone who
liked my feet because of a foot
sculpture i made i've also got a story
about how i dated an undercover insole
for a whole year
wait until
my boyfriend i have watched y'all for
years probably blessed
i want to know what an undercover incel
is did you [ __ ] him or not
you dated him for a year did you [ __ ]
him right he would
right he would no longer be was he
pretending to have sex with her but then
didn't you know what i mean
i donated it twice last week can i
please share my wiping techniques
people need to hear this yeah i mean i'm
interested if it's a unique
fences the danny days in israel never
won
one no how is john doing sean's doing
great
yeah he's doing great he's not fortunate
not
nearby so did you fix it dan
uh yeah i think so yeah so
can i get a shout out to my fiance okay
tomorrow will be our four-year day
every kiss begins with kate
blood diamonds from africa every kiss
begins with
the blood of africans mining away for
for a stone that really is worth not
that much
objectively and is just because it's uh
um
it is exactly 12 39 it isn't after dark
you skanks
skank why am i skank it's after dark in
this room don't you see the lighting
yeah it's after dark souls here's what
you want to do you want to complain
mentally let me do you a favor
don't watch it until what time is after
dark for you
watch it then problem solved thank you
for watching eli have you ever
considered producing jeff dunham
f dolls or implementing the design into
teddy fresh
no you kidding big no
we've left that behind us the jeff
dunham [ __ ] up
the whole you know people don't know how
awful they were
people don't even know the origin but we
used to have a website called
jeffdunhamfuckdolls.com
it's such a weird story i'd have to find
the video tv
really stupid i tried i was trying
sewing i didn't know anything
you left the tag on okay that's part of
the look
you do that on purpose is it important
to the show
well it's just kind of funny you've got
the tag on no i was dressing really
quickly
to get here on time and then you guys
were just
late can i watch can i
can i get to ken uh kenny please yes
thank you okay lenny kenny give me a
break will you get him
forget about it good morning good
[Music]
morning
would you [ __ ] him just be honest not my
type
oh really what is your type it's i know
it's not me
good morning why why do you say that
well i mean like i'm married to you
well no i mean like okay like your
celebrity crush let's say
celebrity crush would not be lenny
kravitz is that's what i mean when i say
not my time who's your celebrity crush
i'm not walking around having a crush
but if i have to like
yeah pick someone yeah um
i'm more in the leonardo leonardo
yeah classic beauty yeah but
i really hate that he dates like 19 year
olds that's a major
you're just mad you're just you're just
mad because that he because you're out
of his age range
even though he's like 20 years older you
can't look at the same way
and then someone is like 50 and he's
dating a 19 year old
yeah he's he's getting meme done a lot
for it too like well it's like
get over it yeah you can get any girl
you want okay what else do you want in
life isn't it there's another layer to
the weirdness right because he also
always breaks up with them at the same
age yeah
like 23 years when they hit 23 or 24 he
breaks up with them
and it's it's always at the same point
you know it's weird because he
he seems like a decent guy from what
little
minuscule amount i know about him but i
guess he just he
the thing is like it's not just like the
he they're just i think it's the good
looks i think it went to his head and
he just can't leave a normal life
anymore
um but yeah of course i mean
yeah he's super desirable i mean he's
like the most desirable man in the world
he's rich he's famous
you gotta you need like you know a5
wagyu beef
all the time you know what i'm saying
dude [ __ ] the dude fox
but i think he's it's got to be more
even so that he's attracted to like
because let's face it no matter how like
smart or whatever
a person is evolved at the age of like
18
19 they're just they're super immature
and dumb
which is why i don't which is really
embarrassing if you're a 50 year old and
you like the company of an 18 year old
yeah
because like it's just i don't know but
it's that waggle beef you know perfect
marbling
what the [ __ ] anyway
zach would [ __ ] lenny kravitz before uh
elo would
yeah he's a guitar hero he's he's not my
type i don't like that i don't like that
ring the denim vest everything
he's the [ __ ] no he where he is what i
can't hear
he's the [ __ ] like that dude is that
[ __ ] i think coolness comes from like
not trying yeah he's trying so [ __ ]
hard
everything he does is perfectly
manicured to be like hey
i hope you're having a good day like
he's trying so hard to be cool don't you
find that a little corny
no like i just i that dude is such a
great guitar player like i feel like
he's earned it
because like the cool rock stars from
the 60s they were all
just like i don't give a [ __ ] i'm gonna
wear like crazy [ __ ]
and they set these trends because they
really didn't give a [ __ ]
like hendricks hendricks that was
totally jimmy
all right let's watch this try not to
get wet zach
hope you all are well hope you are well
i just wanted to let you know that i've
written a memoir called let love rule
why is he talking like that book is
about the first 25 years of my life
culminating in the release of my first
album
those years shaped me it's flirting with
you look at his glasses you can see
reflection
i think he's reading into this day you
see something here i feel like he's
there's a phone and
hang on wait that's the person recording
maybe in the phone recording well i
gotta see what's in his glasses
hey everyone that you normally see i
really like jewel tones
emerald green or mustard what am i
hearing
yeah what's going on it might have been
me my bad
television it's a message i stand for
and live by forever
i'm looking forward to sharing my
journey with you okay you want proof
sorry but you don't talk like that
like just talk like normal i'm
i wrote a memoir okay zach here's proof
that he's not that dope
did you buy his book uh no would you buy
his book
i think so yeah yeah right i dare you to
okay would you read his book if you
bought it
i'm sure that guy's got amazing stories
all right so [ __ ] read it and give me
a synopsis because i don't believe it
right book report next week
i don't [ __ ] believe you would get
past one 10 pages of that [ __ ]
i really don't hope you're all hanging
in there i hope you're all hanging in
there
okay i don't know why i got back i have
to watch this hey everyone i hope you
all are well
i just wanted to let you know that i've
written a memoir called let love man
and why book is about the first 25 years
of my life culminating in the release of
my first album
wow those years shaped me
you know taught me so much about myself
like everybody first 24 years
of love and unity that i still believe
in to this day
it's a message i stand for and will live
by forever
mine i'm looking forward to sharing my
journey with you
lenny kravitz let love on october 6th oh
it's not out yet
i hope you enjoy it i hope you enjoy it
and i hope you see you out on the road
peace
peace okay zach october 6 you better buy
and read that book
i'm writing you know he's also jewish
too oh he is
he's like a happy yeah that's pretty so
happy
yeah from now he's cool yeah i like him
you're right he does have a big dick
i'm sure that comes from the jewish
house zach i
i i'll buy you that book if you read it
150 percent oh my god let's buy them
i i [ __ ] dare you to read that book
bro
you know what you gotta do we gotta
secretly also read it and then quiz him
on it
yeah i'll have a b dude i don't want to
read it i'll have somebody do that you
don't want to read the memoir
no zach won't lie zach never lies he's
an honest adam
plus though that's my stuff uh
i said it's right down my alley that
kind of book okay i'll buy you this
there's a johnny depp video with the
same vibes
oh johnny depp has a video i have to
watch that oh yeah
i think when i was younger i had a
johnny depp yeah well i
yeah i think everybody did because
that's it he's like the cl
him i would say leonardo and johnny yeah
and brad pitt
yeah it's just like that time they were
like they're perfect beauty
yeah yeah and they're cool as [ __ ] but
now he's a total [ __ ] mess
but the thing is you just i feel like
where's this video by the way did you
send it to me
yeah it's on the discord why is the icon
brought so like
it's confusing like at least
like here's why i always get confused
that's a reason to develop how funny
that sounds right
i mean it's funny but like i'm always
confused on discord because i'm an old
[ __ ] you're not showing should i not
show this all right
i don't know anything about discord but
i feel like you shouldn't show it
it was okay i don't think it matters but
like i'm all
you guys know i'm old boomer ass and i
always get confused on discord
so the one with all of our members is
has a
logo of the podcast which is what i
would expect
right to click and then but the one for
us has just a picture of brazil's fat
stupid [ __ ] face
so that's why because i'm always alive
and i don't know what the [ __ ] going
on
okay it's brachio's face okay i'm being
gazed up
okay boomer
so i think these people just forget how
to talk like normal people
because i feel like they they uh they
kind of forget that they're normal
people
like you're not fooling anyone with your
memoir bro you're just this is the thing
you're literally an actor your manager
just came to you and was like hey we got
a book deal you want to do a book deal
they're like dude no
this is exactly i'll tell you exactly
what happens they go
they go lenny that's his name right
lenny you're leaving money on the table
buddy yeah
we can make two three million bucks
you'll get a ghost writer you won't even
have to do anything
spend an afternoon telling this ghost
writer your stories
he'll rate the whole book two three
million bucks and then
that's it oh and and we got the perfect
way for you to sell the book
there's this new service where you give
people your phone call me
and then you get their data and then you
sell them
and stay in touch and it's like i'd like
to be in touch with you yeah let's
continue to let love
rule let's continue to let love wrote
but you know what i feel like um
yeah i don't know people it really goes
to people's heads and they forget how to
talk like normal human beings
but i i find the whole fetishing of
actors funny because like
being a good actor literally says
nothing about you as a human being
well that's the same about any celebrity
like being a good singer
well at least don't say anything about
you as a person
uh right well it says a lot more because
it's like your music and you're writing
words and
emotions and expressions and stuff i
guess if you wrote it but yeah
but yeah i mean of all the all the
performing arts people fetishize them
like gods and
they're just [ __ ] most of the time i
think a lot of
social media is really this is why we're
doing that because now
you hear everyone's thoughts and yeah
and we don't you didn't hear like jimmy
jimi hendrix tweet what he thought about
trump oh
yeah whatever oh my god can you imagine
jimi hendrix
hey everybody yeah you don't want that
is this part of his instagram video the
countdown
like do you see what a big he thinks
this is so important his first ever
instagram post
oh it was okay yeah yeah he had a
countdown this was part of his instagram
post
first ever instagram post he really want
he really thinks it's that important
crazy let's get some hattie's skin
get some howdies hey is it a dungeon or
what
everyone hello it's like a
yeah vampire feel like johnny depp
really lost it when he
started to really think he was captain
jack yeah
because like he started he started
becoming more and more captain
jack-esque
and he started doing other movies and he
was still captain jack
like i remember he was in tonto the
[ __ ]
what was it that he played like
about lone ranger yeah he was captain
jack in that film
it was so stupid it's like he choses
captain jack now
he has a big captain jack tattoo on his
arm oh he does
yeah it wasn't just for the movie that's
you your cat you don't need a tattoo of
you
yeah he's like wait so instagram
highlights is that gonna go to
festivals or where is it gonna play
are we up for awards you know what gets
me is
how many candles are in the shot how
many of you oh wow i didn't see these
ones on the table
the ones behind him yeah bro what are
you doing where is this this is
instagram [ __ ] this is not the
point
like he's totally missing the point of
instagram right
um this is my first experience within
the
world of social media i've
never done any of this before i'm sure
this was the last uh
i don't think i've really ever felt any
particular reason to
until now um
yeah dude what is wrong with you doug
who told you this was a good idea
just get the phone put in your face
people would be so stoked if he just
took the phone and was like
hey guys i'm on instagram yeah see you
tomorrow and people were like yeah he
gets it
hey guys it's my first experience
it's not a dialogue that's the point
it's not a dialogue
you just say [ __ ] and people watch you
say [ __ ]
it's not a dialogue and don't pretend
it's a dialogue
[Laughter]
[ __ ] enemy has already caused
miserable tragedies and enormous damage
to people's lives
um people are ill what is he talking
about i don't care
about the situation with him and amber
heard fighting from
frighteningly high rates
why are you in a dungeon talking about
this [ __ ]
they provide for their children and
their families as a result of this
it does seem like at the end of this
you'll just climb into a coffin
he's like all right good night
some have lost their job
i can't follow him it's just it's the
ramblings of a
[ __ ]
i think he's cool too i mean he used to
be super cool but
now he's just kind of burned out and
weird because you have to age gracefully
you can't be the same cool guy you were
when you were 18 you have to age
gracefully
right you get that's the problem with
all these rock and rollers
i feel like especially with the the good
looker
guys because they're just so stuck in
how good their life when they were 20
right and they're lo but but like you
can look good you just you have to
age out you can look great you know
definitely you can still get that a5
probably get more of it a5 wago beef
what is a5 oh it's the highest tier of
wagyu beef from
japan it's like perfect marbling 1 285
yeah are you drinking that up i'm not
elo how dare you
i'm gonna buy some soon you know costco
sells it
it's like two it's like 150 dollars a
pound some meat wow
obvi the thing is with like leo and like
johnny they've been
on the meat show so long they've been
longer they've been famous longer than
they haven't been since they were like
kids so they don't know how to be normal
i feel like
well that's true
[Music]
i feel like there's got to be some other
other famous people that are normal
well no i mean i get it you've been
famous that long
they're basically child actors yeah and
then they've been [ __ ] like crazy
making tons of money
you know i get it but still
these guys need someone in their life to
be like dude this is not instagram bro
this is like [ __ ]
this shouldn't exist this is nothing
there's always something to do always
our heroes jeff beck
like what the god damn eight minutes of
rambling
it's unwatchable
i hate it speaking of celebrities we've
got a fun look everyone
hey everyone we've got a fun um
segment let's take a call first
we got calls lined up after the call
we've got
celebrity songs some really unknown gems
and really bad ones
really that we're gonna rank um
joe pesci has one where he says
eat my ass he says eat my ass out
treat all your broads like trash
[Laughter]
i swear i swear that's what he says here
i'll play for you real fast
joe pesci wise guy apparently he tried
to scrub the internet of this right
yeah yeah we tried to that's why this is
like 10 pixels this video
yeah it is embarrassing but and it's got
like look how many
uh watermarks are
we should add one yo we should add one
and upload it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is the worst thing ever this is
worse than johnny depp's dungeon
[Music]
my ass i don't hear anything eat out my
ass ate up my feet out my head
when you slow it down it sounds even
more like you're saying it let me hear
it
what johnny thought anyway we'll watch
this but let's take a call um there's
someone in hebrew
writing that he has a big problem after
his fiancee
left him and he would like advice okay
he's been listening to us for three
years
or watching sorry i like to give advice
and you would
yeah yeah bring him on i don't know how
contact zach on discord dm me on discord
yeah
it's this guy that's typing in hebrew
yeah leon
is his quest is his question going to be
in hebrew hopefully
i can't translate that's not going to
work
um but until then let's get gabe
see this one's tough you guys i don't
know
this girl she loves the smell and touch
of her period blood
so much that she uses special underwear
called thinx what that has a pad built
into it you're supposed to just rinse
it and wring it out so she does this so
she can save it
all of her period blood and so she puts
it in her faucet
she also has a uh it's called
endo endotraceosis which makes her
periods even heavier and longer
oh god what a nightmare she wants to
share
i feel like she just sharing you guys
want to hear that i feel like it might
be too gross
people are saying no yeah i don't know
i i mean i i just heard the story
actually like from you
yeah i mean i heard that i read that and
i was like guys this is too gross but
then we had this whole philosophical
bible why isn't that the whole point
but i was like well
yes and no you know like i don't want it
to be so gross that everyone's like
out nope nope nope um everyone's
screaming
no so what kind of show is it when
you're
literally doing something that
literally nobody we're like period
shaming i don't think that's
an issue because you're saying like what
are you saying that you guys had a
debate about what
no if it was too gross to put on the
show well because when we were talking
about it last night ethan was too gross
it was too gross i was like well this is
i mean
we're doing after dark it's supposed to
be yeah supposedly
no no no no um yeah but
so here's another one the chat is is
heartbeat yeah i haven't seen the single
player yeah everyone's ready
discord is saying yes though no i'm not
doing it i'm not doing it
well okay i feel like we've talked about
period blood enough and
some girls like it some don't it's crazy
some girls like
it i really hate it i freaking hate it
is there any weird smells you like
though because like you did not you deny
even ever like
smelling your own well you say you smell
your own farts but i don't say i
i don't enjoy it you don't enjoy it no
not even like i don't believe you do you
do i don't like it
how dare you we had a whole debate about
it yeah we're already talking yeah okay
next do we have the guy who needs advice
if not i've got rosie here not yet i can
throw rosie yeah let's get rosie in let
me set it up
so rosie has a door an incident
in her dorm that they call poop lasagna
it was so bad the person in charge of
the entire dorm had to send out
emails telling us to stop the issue was
that
wait wait don't explain it why i'm
setting it up
but don't explain what it actually is i
know what poop lasagna is
it's a known phenomenon well what i know
poop lasagna is as when you take a poop
and then you wipe and then you do and
then you discover you have to poop more
so you poop on the toilet paper and then
you wipe again you have a poop lasagna
okay
okay so anyway this kept happening
and the paper will clog the toilet then
another person would come try to flush
it wouldn't work so they would poop on
top of it which i
don't believe anyone would do unless
there was literally no other toilet
can you imagine [ __ ] on top of like
that
mess of toilet paper and dump that you
see sometimes in publix hauls that would
i would never i would never
i'd rather ship my pants i'd rather [ __ ]
on the floor next to the toilet
i would just yeah i would just leave
whatever i'm doing and just
just exit on that day just it's not
happening
just go home just from the dorm you're
out of state
you're at it
first flight out of here anyway they
would poop on it
cover it and it was just apparent see i
i don't think
i don't believe her i'm gonna call her
out she sent receipts though
like apparently she has letters it says
hello residents
um there's been reports of excessive
toilet paper
and towels being thrown on the toilet
more specifically an incident involving
paper towels on the floor
stopping up the toilets with excess
paper and overflowing and then
using paper at a rate of a whole roll a
day
layering the paper and poop without
flushing in other words
putting some paper i love how she
clarifies in other words
putting some paper in the toilet pooping
on it
covering it with more paper and then the
person adds more paper and poops
doesn't flush oh what people were doing
that on purpose
that's wait on purpose why this this
email makes it sound like they were
doing it as a gag
ew i can see some dorm [ __ ]
meat heads doing that as a gag
so then it was like unflushable who are
you
who's the guy i don't know it's just
something dumb you think's funny like
i could see that that makes more sense
to me than when i first this
is sick that's true she she posted an
excel of the damages
um i don't know if you can read it i'm
trying to see if i can zoom in here
this i thought this was pretty funny
like this is kind of a week
week of flight she's saying bring her on
i'm trying i'm waiting for you guys
well no she's ready i was i will bring
her in what the hell she's in here i'm
trying to hold the show
i'm waiting for her she's in the room
oh my god she's on the call right now
rosie what what's going on dude so
rosie can you hear me yes hello hi
okay so was this a gag like tell me was
this a gag that people were like
pooping on each other's poop or was it
the toilet clogged
so this resulted in the toilet being
clogged also discord says
um no so this was not a gagged
this is not a gag but this was the
international theme
dorm so myself included we all come from
places where you know bidet is a thing
so even for me i just did not know how
to
use paper so indeed like using
words and of papers so all the free
the international freaks came together
and didn't know how to use the toilet
that makes more sense
so wait hold on rosie where are you from
you're from i think norway i read
no no no netherlands oh netherlands no
no and um
and you were studying in in the united
states at the time at whit at
where indiana university
shout out so where you are from
every day is just normal everyone's got
it
yeah my parents were originally
pakistani so we have like a hose
next to the toilet oh okay yeah there's
like a little
separate day or you use it here was just
a totally
unknown that makes way more sense i've i
i've seen that hose like as a kid and
i've in
some places i feel like everybody in
israel there i never knew what you're
supposed to do
that's so funny it's the temperature to
pressure ratio
but i just feel like you splash ass
water all over your hands
i mean your hands getting cleaned as
well yeah but okay well anyway let's
stick to the topic
i could debate you on wiping techniques
all day
so so you had a bunch of international
students in uh
in a dorm room yes and you guys were
using too much toilet paper
is what it sounds like a
yeah that doesn't seem like a lot i mean
it depends how many people were there
no yeah so let's say they're
25 dollars two people per room dude
that's
absolutely reasonable a roll a day
let me clarify was there just one toilet
for everybody
three three four men three for women on
one floor
okay and this was happening in the men's
and the women's or just the men's
yes it was okay so this university had
13 dorms
each dorm had multiple buildings and
they did a thing where they ranked
each floor in all the dorms together for
like sanitation
and the three floors in my dorm building
came last against the entire dorms which
has to be around like 100 floors
and it was because of like one people
shot in the shower
every single year that i was there oh
and then also because
it was like our building specifically
because we had people poop
if you look at the the cost dude i know
what you're saying
no it's the international students
because i had students
i that also happened in my dorm room
when i was a freshman i remember because
people will come from like
indonesia or somewhere where they just
they don't even have like toilets
and they they didn't know how to [ __ ]
and they were just [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
shower and waffle stop it bro
that's what happened it got waffle
stomped and if you look at the bill
it's clearly says had to dig it out was
stomped in
oh i feel so bad for them now now it all
makes sense and i feel so bad
we could smell it the hallway was quite
vile
so wait so when you needed to go to the
bathroom what would you do
did you ever poop on top did you ever
contribute to the poop lasagna
maybe yes so this is a story in itself
so okay so um since you cancelled out
periods uh
i was on my period and you know it gives
you period poops
stop the clock what's a period poop i've
never heard of that
do you know what that is because i'm not
sure
it's when your body your body is
cramping to get the blood out and the
lining out
but it's also pushed against your colon
so
it gives you like diarrhea as well
because not only is the blood and the
pot coming out so is the poop
i don't know that delightful yeah i
just love being on period it's just like
oh you don't get to wake up
how come you don't get period poops you
don't have diarrhea on your period
i mean i s well i i thought it only
depends on what i eat because
it's not all you never linked the two no
i didn't
do but who knows maybe i'm different
girls get way unaware okay well
at any rate you had a period poop
i was on my period i took coffee before
a two-hour session
and by the end of the session i was
dying so i just ran home and of course
the only stall
available has been to have the one with
the lasagna
in it and i'm dying i don't have
a choice i just go in and
i mean first of all
i mean it's at least like f it's the end
of the day so i mean
if i flush it's going to overflow so you
know just put a little bit of paper down
prevent a splash oh you'd contributed to
the poop lasagna
fro like diarrhea for 20 minutes
and that is the worst part i don't know
how to use
paper so it's just like like i don't
feel
clean so it's like okay i just got to
keep on piping
wiping drop wiping drop and then the
worst
part is the worst part is like i could
feel
like the wet like the lasagna on my butt
like and and i had to leave it then just
shower because if i flushed everything
just won't move it just physically does
not move yeah you wouldn't you couldn't
even flush you just make matters worse
you know um you know
you know what's funny is the people in
the stall the the two other stalls knew
you were pooping on the
on the poop lasagna because they they
probably checked that stall and we're
like oh i'm not going in there but then
you went in there
yes and the thing is it happened on a
daily basis
wow so what were you supposed to do i
mean
were there other toilets yeah i would
just probably go to a different dorm was
that an option
no because you only had access to your
own building i mean you could go to
another floor but it was happening on
all three floors
so why was your why was your like
why was this person in charge giving you
guys [ __ ] over 34 for extra
toilet paper i mean what the [ __ ] is
this
i mean we shot in the if you look at the
bill we shot in the shower
everyone had to pay for these bills by
the way even though oh they charged you
yeah not just me everyone on the floor
oh my god
that final bill wait that's for every
single individual
it was divided up by 50 or however it's
very small
yeah someone appeared on three yeah i
wanted to read that one it says someone
peed on three couches and surrounding
area around couches and vomit in the
hallway
it's college bro oh my god good times
i can't imagine that american college
experience
i have in israel it's different like
that i remember that [ __ ] was a little
extra weird in the international one
because of situations like she
like i remember there was rumors about
the international one like
that people were pooping in buckets and
that
um and it wasn't their fault they just
didn't know any better you know i mean
yeah
and and people would shave their cubes
on the toilet seats and leave it there
oh my god that's what
that one's hard to justify why not do
that you know if if they're
out my [ __ ] in the shower [ __ ] it if i
wasn't
i can't imagine forcing it down the
drain with my feet though but regardless
rosie
no i was just gonna say it became the
legacy of foster shade
floor 2 because i lived there for 3-4
years and it happened every single year
man here we have an itemized bill
vomit cleanup south sub-hallway
vomit cleanup and sinks two and three
you know i would think that a cleaning
service would be included in the price
of admission though
um yes we had a custodian who was there
every day but for
this they brought in the big boys oh the
hazmats and all that
like i'm not joking that's a pretty
reasonable price then
i feel like uh cleaning up feces and
mint shower 45 bucks are you kidding me
i want to clean up feces for 45 bucks
yeah even at my worst you'd have to pay
me a lot more than that
although how do you clean up feces in
the shower you just turned the water on
no it was waffle
depends yeah if it's been stomped ethan
i just want to point out
you see two bills for the poop in the
shower we were only aware of
one poop in the shower until we got the
bill
yeah and turns out that the other person
did it and just didn't get caught
cleaned up dried
whoa hang on dried feces smashed into
shower drain had to dig it out what does
that mean
how do you have dried feces in a shower
drain um
i think that one happened over like the
crisp and the break oh no
like the one week break we had that's
why nobody knew about it
wow oh
that's crazy dude what a legacy
this is sick it's not like a legacy
well you know what college is great
and uh and i share that i have similar
experiences all this is fantastic
that you have it documented so well
welcome thank you for sharing rosie and
i'm glad you had a good time in america
and we represented well
do you have a functioning toilet now do
you feel
uh yeah i mean i wipe my butt with my
hand
and i have a little bucket like a little
measuring jar that you fill with water
and then it's called the loca in
pakistan in india
you just pour a little bit and then you
wipe with your left hand
just straight raw
yeah and he thought that was the most
clean way you feel like it's clean you
feel like your hand
do not like have to bleach your hand
like literally like how do you feel like
once you've touched [ __ ] because once i
touch [ __ ] it happens on accident
occasionally when i'm wiping it feels
like you know
armageddon i mean it feels really bad so
so how do i
lie sometimes after washing my hand it
still smells like poop so i have to like
use hand sanitizer to like get the smell
out so it doesn't touch doesn't that
tell you that maybe there's a better way
what a dry paper towel well a bidet or
or yeah i thought you were about the
yeah bidet why are we putting our hand
in there
i mean the bidet is basically just water
without the hand
or do you not have the option of a bidet
uh i mean
i i like culture like my first few years
were in pakistan
and yeah i like it i mean you can get
into the
when you're kiki in the bedroom and what
like i know it's like
what is it like there's the uh the right
hand for eating the left hand for wiping
right
yes so is there any kind of like kinks
with the left hand in the bath
in the bedroom because it's like the
dirty hand
um like if you put your left fingers in
the mouth or something
oh i'd be grossed out really that's the
white pad yeah i was just curious
because it's like interesting
okay all righty well any questions
so if you make hands you only use the
right hand
i mean i'm personally not weird about
this but some people
like do are like tabooed about it like
oh eat with your right hand come on
hmm i i mean i get that if i touch if i
mean look
if i was putting my left hand up my ass
i would probably eat with my right hand
but like i mean it works for you and you
seem really happy and well adjusted so
keep doing your thing man
thank you i mean if you go out and play
in mud do you just use a paper towel or
do you take a shower
right well you you've been through
you've been through worse it sounds like
the lasagna touched my butt yeah
[Laughter]
nothing will ever compete with that
experience
[Music]
all right rosie stay well and uh
keep that left hand clean all right
thank you rosie um i
really quickly recommend the film toilet
man it's a bollywood film
just watch it okay toilet man i'm on it
you're interested it'll be about you
ethan
thanks rosie all right bye rosie bye bye
that was more interesting than i
expected and to be told she turned it
around i mean you were totally skeptical
that story was even real
yeah she convinced me when i found out
it was in the um the international
because i had the same exact thing i
swear to god it was it was
it was uh chaos there you know
[ __ ] that was gross
but that's that's the beauty of college
life that people don't think about
but that [ __ ] happens in every college
everywhere in every dorm just [ __ ] like
that you know the first time i ever saw
period blood in a toilet i had a co-ed
bathroom
in college and girls would leave period
blood in the toilet
and i had never seen anything like that
before and i was just like
why why not just flush i think maybe
what happens
is that they flush but it doesn't go
down because it's like you can tell it's
like super heavy
yeah so it like settles on the bottom of
the toilet and i was just like
oh my god i mean it's just it's shocking
it's not i'm not like
i'm not trying to be judgmental it's
just i never seen that before and i'm in
a public restroom i was just like oh
god it was dramatic yeah
but it's weird to like shower
next to women i mean you had like a
stall they were in like stalls with a
curtain
super weird so what do you do when you
get out
you just wear a towel and people go to
their room to get dressed
or you stay in the shower there's like a
bench
i see yeah crazy yeah it was pretty
pretty wild times okay
what were we talking about
oh we're going to do the the celebrity
um
i'm going to read off a couple super
chats real quick yeah i'm going to pee
go for it
or i don't know if i want to dip out on
the super chat i can hear him
i can hear him from the bathroom go
ahead uh okay let's see
uh i'm trying to see where you last left
off here
um uh do we read jetpack hero hey guys
i've been a huge fan
since forever you guys helped me through
a recent breakup i love you guys just
became a member
and i'm wearing my teddy fresh
sweatshirt right now very cool
thank you sorry about your breakup i'm
glad we could uh
get you through that uh oh this was the
jeff dunham thing we already
asked about that shout out to aien my
true love shout out
you guys uh would love to share with you
guys how my family
infected over 40 people with copenhagen
i 19. if you're in the discord hit up
yeah that does sound interesting
uh let's see uh
you have a story to make ethan laugh i
think it's a good one if i can be the
contestant today
jake hit up zach if you're in the
discord uh
hit them up uh let's see i saw some
really big ones i want to make sure i
get to them
uh thirty dollar one message retracted
well thank you nicole
uh i don't know why you retracted your
message but thank you for the thirty
uh devin can i get a shout out for
myself
i love you guys so much and these
podcasts make my day and give me
something to look forward to well shout
out devon
shout out to yourself zach i absolutely
love your song covers on instagram i
wish i could save them into a playlist
and listen
since we've got the same music pace you
should uh you should like create a
youtube channel and throw them up on
there exactly yeah for sure
so that appreciate it ian's flow
uh somebody says ethan consider the
uh keto diet well zach's already
advocated heavily for that i don't think
it's gonna happen
i like to die on i just honestly i i
like the diet i feel healthy i just
i just gotta hold it for i mean it's
only been a week right i just gotta hold
it
i feel better on it you know i just
gotta hold it yep
oh by the way i meant to post this uh uh
the last person who worked on aien whose
name i couldn't remember is brooke
and uh i if you're in the uh
chat right now i'm gonna spam all three
both justin
ben and brooke's instagram handles go
check them out
really talented people um so i have a
question
um we're doing the celebrity uh
songs we're going to rank them do we
have some kind of tier list set up or
are we just going to do this free ball i
think we got to just free ball it
so let me open like a um photoshop
document and i can just like
this is so stupid there's gotta be a
better way
um
you just do it in a text document
honestly i mean just write them yeah
that's the best word i'll be easy yeah
yeah
thank you all right so ela we're going
to
be doing celebrity uh songs and
unfortunately we're going to be doing a
tier list
and a word doc oh yeah epic so we have
joe
or we have eddie murphy first you know
you know eddie murphy why is it so small
my god it's here let me open a [ __ ]
google drive doc there you go there you
go
eddie murphy is like such a talent when
it comes to um
impressions and sinking he has a
beautiful voice but he keeps trying to
make
music and it's always just horrible
disagrees with that oh zach give me a
[ __ ] break
excuse me oh my god you really have a
problem you like everything
and that that song is the greatest
[ __ ] song
ever it's exactly how you're supposed to
feel
as you're like you like me you're a fan
and all that right like that's how you
that's why you work for us
how am i supposed to take that when you
like all the [ __ ] you like
i like a lot of things but there are
things that i do dislike that would
i strongly accept anything but mike on
impulsive is the only thing you dislike
shorts and birds all right so let's
watch
uh eddie murphy party all the time
note from zach this is my favorite song
of all time
yeah along with every other song you've
[Music]
heard
oh wow it has a lot of views i thought
you're saying wait damn 50 million
anyway that's it uh you know it's not
that bad it's not that bad actually
it doesn't even deserve it it shouldn't
even be on the list eddie
i love you joe pesci now we're talking
now we're getting into music that
shouldn't exist
joe pesci you know it's an interesting
phenomenon there's so many celebrities i
i just i included discluded a lot of
stuff that i thought wasn't bad enough
to be on the list but there's so many
celebrities with songs gwyneth paltrow
has a song
um what's her name the [ __ ] the girl
uh scarlett johansson scarlett joel
hansen has a song
really there's like it's it's a it's an
epidemic
steven seagal stevenson has a song for
christ
the idea of someone else's idea i think
it's his idea
we did a little research apparently joe
pesci uh wanted to
be a musician um and his father was the
one that pushed him into smashing
instead yes
there was no resemblance of musical
talent
it was apparently his original dream and
so once he became a very successful
actor he um
you know leveraged that into uh
releasing some albums this song is
actually off of his second album
what yep what
well so far for me that one is number
one number one
one of one one one of one but how do you
top that yeah
i feel like we started with the best eat
out her ass treat it like trash
it's the [ __ ] that'll get you he's
kind of ahead of the time like
eat up my ass
um okay well vin diesel we watched with
tom and christina but
nobody's seen that yet that's yeah we
should watch oh we haven't yeah okay
great
oh well this is exciting then because
yeah wait
i want the i don't want this i want the
um the big premiere
you want it on yeah so vin diesel friend
of the show obviously
put out a [ __ ] song put out a song
vin diesel arvind diesel on the chloe
kelly clarkson show
and obviously because of the pandemic
they weren't able to have a live
audience and so they
zipped everybody in on these little
screens
nerf ultra five blast up to 120 feet
with a four dart
yo who's playing commercials [ __ ] is
going on what's going on that's the
second time that's happened
you guys all right who's responsible for
the nerf blast commercial what's up
that's me that's me that's me all right
no more commercials
i was watching something for ela how
many
[Laughter]
we're just starting to like you kid
all right man i'd love to be in that
audience though like what an opportunity
you know front row seat why are they
yeah i mean it's not as bad as joe pesci
but
no it's not unfortunately but it is
pretty embarrassing for our boy
uh vin who by the way has a flawless uh
so far reputation um
did i close my document did i really do
that
i'm such a i'm such a [ __ ]
or not man accidents happen [ __ ] happens
no but
no but i do it every [ __ ] time like
it's crazy how often i do this [ __ ] okay
boomer
okay boomer so what i got to go open a
new document
does anyone give a [ __ ] what do we need
to write it down for one of my [ __ ]
goldfish you can't remember
i don't think we really care about it i
don't remember here i'll i'll just
i'll write it down earlier i am such a f
all all right i'm just kidding it's not
that serious
i feel like this year list gets a little
tedious like i'm kind of
all right so we got but yeah i mean look
joe pesci is the worst
yeah okay here's david hasselhoff in
1989. in germany
[Applause]
i don't know if you know this meme but
david hasselhoff has a music career in
the united states nobody gave a [ __ ] but
in germany everybody loved them
weirdest thing i think you told me about
it it was so weird
huge in germany you're just huge in
germany remember norm used to
every single when he was on snl and he
was the host of weekend update
every single episode he would make a
joke about david hasselhoff being
super popular in germany he would always
make a point of bringing it up
no matter what the story was he would
find a way to bring up the fact that
david has offered
you oh that's fantastic why is that look
at that piano
look how happy he is jesus
that is that's what david has loved
looking this is david hasselhoff
david why did you want to come exactly
here to the run gate
one year ago we did looking for freedom
and it was a dream
this is more meme worthy than anything
okay just making sure
just doing a vibe check on you
[Music]
yeah i can't handle this but again i
mean you can't beat joe
i eat him knew it i knew that we started
with the best as soon as okay well hold
on
william shatner made a whole album of
what
this here he made a whole [ __ ] album
let me remind you ela that this is not
a joke this photoshop is it was this the
real cover
i think so it's a real ongoing
wow that's amazing
so so this is real i guess he did a
whole album
covering um david bowie is that what
happened
it was just like an album of like rock's
greatest songs okay
sung by william shatner right yeah
album of this [ __ ] here let me go
forward oh my god
wait how does he
[Music]
i know the queen song
it really matters like instead of
listening to freddie mercury maybe you
just want to listen to some old
[ __ ] putty dude talk in a monotone
voice over your favorite songs
[Laughter]
nothing really matters
the middle section i feel like is going
to be the best that's the weird operatic
part
but imagine thinking this is better than
the original or as
some added value to it or just anything
that anyone else would want to listen to
except yourself
god he wants me on drugs bye everybody
that's [ __ ] awesome someone said you
guys have to listen to the common people
by william shatner yeah one i feel like
i want more
i feel like this one's too musical like
find me major tom
yeah no his most famous one i think is
rocket man yeah i want rocket man
send me that [ __ ] yeah come on man
what a weird thing to do a whole album
bro
they're saying common people is the one
we should check out so let's check out
common people and rocket man
all right and like the list of musicians
that worked on this cover album is
insane
goodbye everybody i love how genuine he
is like just sounds like he's talking
over like the karaoke version
but it no the music sounded good to me
yeah but it sounds like it's just
they're a-b
oh yeah yeah yeah it's just the
instrumental of them yeah
okay here we go this is called common
people
by william well to be honest i don't
know the original so
so here give me rocket man that song i
know
just type it into youtube it'll come
right up
i demand a concierge service tim
oh this one's got a video a lyricist
whose string of hits
in collaboration with elton john has
made him one of the world's most popular
songwriters please welcome bernie toppin
i'd like you to see william chat i was
like
let me fast forward this [ __ ] yeah at
the sign last night
okay here we go this is [ __ ] serious
bro
she packed my bags
last night pre-flight
zero hour people are laughing
and i'm gonna be high
dude how are people not laughing there's
a kite
by them
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] insane i miss the
earth
so much
how is this better this is just like a
performance
art like not really it's lonely
how is it additive on such a
timeless i think elton john did a
perfectly fine
job enunciating the words
and i think it's going to be a long long
time
brings me back again to find i'm by the
way this website is called
fuzzymemories.tv which is exactly what
this is man
it's perfect i'm a rocket man the top
comment is nobody plays the cigarette
like william shatner
[Music]
[Music]
i just can't deal with this
i could watch this all day but i mean
the fact that this exists in front of a
live
audience that's right i gotta hear how
this guy introduced him
due to the interest in the meaning of
the song now in 1978
at the science fiction film awards i'm
truly proud
once again to present my rocket man as
interpreted by our host
william shatner thank you wow dude i
don't know how people didn't laugh
in his [ __ ] face
oh that's hot well how does shatner rank
with i mean nobody eats eat my ass
number two yeah he's number two for sure
real quick are you guys seeing all this
about
uh james charles lie detector test video
no why is it good should i watch it
james charles took a lie detector test
and one of the questions was did you
actually copy teddy fresh he said no and
the guy said he wasn't lying
oh well so what
i'm just telling you what i'm seeing
wait where is it jim where's this video
james charles lied to text there
it's in the discord i put ian sent a
little bit
okay here it is did you ever
have a thing with noah back did you
actually steal these designs from teddy
fresh jeans
are you subscribed to anybody unholy
fans are you actually a virgin
did you ever get more cosmetic surgery
well this is just the intro
oh it's on his channel hi sisters so
wait this is his it's on his channel
this is his way of addressing it just
being like that's all he said hey hey
dude
this is proof i mean i first of all i i
don't ever suspect that he
did steal it i think someone on his team
did it doesn't matter
james it's still your product it doesn't
matter if you oh did you time set me up
okay cool i'm not gonna [ __ ]
i'm not going to watch this video hi
sisters
i thought he would have actually at
least just gave us a shout out and be
nice about it
let's see the gals want to know
did you actually steal these designs
from teddy fresh no
that's true that guy's a paid actor okay
paid actor all right paid actor you're
off the hook
that settles for everybody all charges
dropped
that guy's a [ __ ] paid actor this
guy's a stooge bro it's on james charles
channel
this guy's a [ __ ] from an infomercial
for diabetes medicine
i'm not calling him fat i'm just saying
he looks like a paid actor and
a bad one at that by the way lie
detectives are pseudoscience i never
accused him personally instead i think
his design team did
and uh all files are being dropped now
though because i have conclusions
yes should i stop i can't believe it
wow i mean
seriously that's all you're gonna say
okay
all right someone said in the comments
is this guy
this guy's the same lie detector guy
that's on everyone they're liars they're
full of [ __ ]
wait what'd you say to me i said someone
in the comments said this is the same
guy that's on everyone's channel as the
as the lie detector he this is the guy
that's what someone in the comments said
yeah what can i ask him wasn't ian
shane's video too is that the same guy
maybe dude you guys know lie detectors
are like the biggest pseudoscience
[ __ ] ever
yeah oh yeah it's not evidence to
anything it's not even allowed in there
yeah it's not even a lot of core and all
you have to do is squeeze your butthole
to fake an answer
because it [ __ ] up your your uh blood
pressure yeah is that real
yeah you literally just squeeze your
[ __ ] and it will [ __ ] up every answer
because it increases your blood pressure
but i love that he thinks that if he
personally didn't know about the hoodie
then it's fine
it's like no you run a company
your employees maybe stole the design
and you didn't know
but it's still your product i'm still
going to talk to you i'm not going to go
talk to one of your employees yeah so if
he had said for example
and i'm not this is open-ended but if he
had come back to you and said
okay we looked into it this designer on
our team
apparently he did steal it from you guys
we've let him go
yeah that's none of my business i don't
care what you do with your team
but like yeah would that have been like
an acceptable response
no that's your business yeah of course
not however you run your company is none
of my business
by the way you think if he really said
yes and it went off he would keep it in
the video
it's his video in his house on his
channel
whatever i mean i don't care but
like the fact that he's gonna parade
this around could you know
that he put it up front this is the
dumbest [ __ ] i thought he would have
done like i thought he would at least
i thought because i saw people say that
he mentioned uh
teddy fresh so i thought maybe you would
have said like hey you know this came up
no he a little shout out for teddy fresh
we didn't mean to steal the design
i thought it was going to be something
something like amicable would be like
okay cool
the gals want to know did you actually
steal these designs from teddy fresh
no take 20.
the first 19 came out negative that's
true
he's like that's true he goes no no no
no see
this is how i know this guy's a quack
you say
it's not that's true it's like um
no there's no receptive yeah there's
there's no receptive of uh perceived lie
or some [ __ ]
yeah he's like i confirm i confirmed
that he didn't steal from teddy fresh
[ __ ] quack-ass [ __ ]
the fact of the matter is you approached
him before it was even released
i mean and he admitted to it and then he
still you know
he still came out when i hit him in the
dms he responded
so [ __ ] fast yeah right he
immediately responded like he was
expecting it to come like a whole
paragraph
i was like hey dude uh you know whatever
whatever
and then immediately it was like boom i
had this [ __ ] prepared by my lawyer
i swear to god
james i have beef with james charles now
[Music]
and you do not want me as an enemy hi
sisters
people are saying he said no before the
question was over exactly
i'm gonna hire this guy as a con i'm
gonna lie to him
that'd be [ __ ] epic hire this guy and
then lie to him a bunch of times
unprovably fake [ __ ] just to ruin his
reputation
you're gonna squeeze your butthole i'll
squeeze my ass and everything
i can't get over this sound bite this
this is great just want to know
did you actually steal these designs
from teddy fresh no
yeah he starts saying no before he
finishes the question
can you do i want to do something where
you just put in yes and then
we'll just play that sound bite you
could just edit from what the ones that
you see
yeah just use that soundbite all the
time wrap that up
can i point out too on his video i'm
trying to find teddy fresh in the
comments and i'm not seeing it anywhere
oh he blocked it he's deleting i totally
blocked
it by the way how do i know he didn't
even just look at this
true that's straight up a stalk and they
just cut that in any time
from any answer that's true
next question did you ever have a thing
with noah back no i wish
yeah he's like yep he's like yep he does
wish that
i got to watch this now because i hate
because i hate you and i want to make
[Laughter]
um do you think that you can beat larry
in a fight watch your mouth lorraine
you mean low ray larry who's supposed to
larry with the
extra a at the end like what kind of
fight oh physical
i guess this for you physical no but in
the lower
okay james charles have you i guess
somebody cares no
ever done a collab with someone you
didn't like
at the time of recording dude you
[ __ ]
no
this guy's full of [ __ ] this guy's full
of [ __ ]
there's definitely people that i've
clogged with oh we know next all right
that's for sure we go
oh he said yes he said yeah
he said yeah a a long time ago but now i
always make sure to do it
okay shut up liar
wow haters are step sisters
step sister we're her step sister
dude he literally he blocked teddy fresh
from the chat
all right sister i see how it is
i wrote for you bro you know
when it came time to show you know
who was the real one i wrote for james
charles
that was true i [ __ ] that now that's a
sound bite
that's true i defended him
i fought for him i'd have died for him
he was my sister
that was true he says this is the same
lie detector guy as david
dobrik uses in his videos
it's not accurate it's like a fad
whatever
yeah but the youtube thing you could
these guys wouldn't put out an
embarrassing answer they obviously would
edit it yeah yeah the comments believe
it that's for sure well yeah sure
these people think that people think lie
detectors are like voodoo magic with
like
they can read your heart and mind you
know what i mean
right hey uh let me ask you a
uh let me ask some questions to the lie
detector guy
um do you uh
are you um just faking all the answers
that's true that's what i thought
is that laptop are you doing anything on
that laptop in front of you or is it
just
on is minecraft open or minesweeper
that's true that's what i figured just
minesweeper
not software or anything do you have any
formal training
yes sir
is it true i heard you have no
no formal training at all
oh he's they're saying get james charles
to be the worst on wikifeet
oh that's dude he already is he already
is
dude you know what happens to my enemies
you know what happens to him
what do you mean he's already got he has
a low rating on wikipedia 1.64
what yo was that did our peeps ride
we never mentioned look at his [ __ ]
feet look at these let's dude his feet
are [ __ ] disgusting i'm just kidding
i don't know
just trying to be but you know what
happens to our enemies right
what happens ethan oh
you know i don't have to say what god's
name is this image
yeah one well guys you know what to do
i'm not telling you to fudge the numbers
i'm just tell what here's what i
encourage you all to do
go to james charles on wikifee and just
share your opinion share your thoughts
give it a rating share your thoughts
but i would refer you specifically to
this image here
as you share your thoughts right ela
that's true that's true whoa wait
what go back one this one
his feet are kind of weird i'm telling
you they're one star bro they ain't
beautiful like mine they're pretty
they're pretty nasty dude yeah the
comments weren't happy
oh let's read the comments they didn't
like the these
they look like the feet of someone who
steals merch
you can tell that from his feet wow
that's true that is true
nasty feet dirty and ugly
for a boy his feet are beautiful hey get
the [ __ ] out of freak
you got weird taste
hmm yeah
i got beef with james charles now
literally i've got beef oh my god his
feet look freakish i mean i'm not trying
to be mean
what the god what's going on there looks
like he's got a goat oof
you know like these human goats they're
like they're like demons
sucker is it a satire it's got a goat
hoof girl
sister um what size what size shoehorn
do you take
all right can we go back to our segments
no this is the segment now first off
this is the segment sister we're at an
hour 45 by the way
yeah well i'm just getting started
sorry step sisters
oh he's just opened a can of [ __ ] [ __ ]
sandwich
fish lasagna shitless poop lasagna bro
that's like a poop lasagna in your
sister's stall
[Laughter]
you know what's coming your way bro
is that how is that a thing you don't
your ass
okay
james is james charles half goat
are
not for human being to be half goat
being the goat
oh the no i said half goat not they'll
go
does james charles have acid implants
that's true i knew it fake ass
yeah oh really
does james charles have a tiny peepee
see i didn't that wasn't even a yes or
no question what do you what are you yet
saying is true
all right how do we move on how do we
move on
is there any more james charles content
we can watch that's funny what's about
that one video of him tripping and
eating [ __ ] we can watch that over and
over
we should probably move on from we
should bring that detector guy
yeah i totally i'm gonna [ __ ]
scrutinize his ass let's do our own
version
i want to see what's going on on his
laptop
what's going on there dude i know you're
playing minesweeper
but if we bring him to do a video with
us
then we get to see the behind the scenes
i don't think he'll do it now
i don't think he'll agree we should get
our own well what we should do is just
dress
zack up like a [ __ ] lie detector and
like
yeah just find some bozo off craigslist
and give him a laptop
and have him go that's true some cables
that's true do you have a 20 inch penis
yes
that's true there you go infallible
what is this oh here this is what i
wanted you guys to watch it's just james
charles eating [ __ ] in a mall
we made it out of line we have the
spiders in hand cardio for me
james charles you just made the worst
enemy of your life
that's true yeah that one come that one
rings true
infallible i'm bringing my own lie
detector and you're going down
hey am i the worst enemy you could ever
make in life
true that's right wait we gotta get a
soundbite of him saying no
we never got one of them saying no yeah
yeah everything is true
this guy's never been fed a single wrong
answer
all right you want to get back to the
yeah so actually this one is
this one actually i think competes with
joe pesci it's kim kardashian used to
make music
look at her hair how big it is look at
her [ __ ] hair anyway this is really
bad
[Music]
i think it reminds me of patricia marie
like straight up dan mom music
[Music]
adam bartoche
[Music]
oh it's turn it up turn it up not tear
me up
i mean this this is like patrice patrice
wilson level of
music production
so i mean
i guess we could wrap it up after this
we have so much content here let's watch
one more corey feldman
this is basically going to be between
corey feldman
kim k and joe pesci
[Music]
what is going on in the music
[Music]
let me fast forward
[Music]
oh my god i just realized i i swear to
[ __ ] god we've been in this house
do you know what i'm talking about we
rewind time
we've been in this house when we were
shopping for houses
and we saw all this weird michael
jackson [ __ ]
that's his [ __ ] that's his [ __ ]
that's where we were bro
it's rewind time when you guys were
talking about it i was wondering if it
was his house that's so funny
i was like i i think that i think that
was his house
[Music]
here let me see i'll wreck it here let
me see
no it's a different backyard
the backyard was so [ __ ] creepy
[Music]
okay anyway this isn't bad i mean it's
has been awful i mean i just feel bad
for him though kind of
yeah it's [ __ ] horrible dude okay wow
i
i thought it was great i thought it was
cool
did i like this song if anyone needs
your love zach it's corey feldman bro
yeah
no seriously all right so you guys want
to take a vote between
kim k corey feldman and joe pesci
i guess we all feel bad for um for corey
so
i mean joe pesci is obviously it's hard
to compete with the eating the ass thing
but
kim k's i think is is probably worse
because like
joe's is just it's like it's kind of fun
and it's kind of fun
and it's weird and wild i say kim k for
sure but kim k is just so embarrassing
she actually denounces the song though
like what does that mean how do you
denounce it
she regrets making it it's your regrets
well i don't blame her for that
of course all these people do joe pesci
tried to race from the internet
she's not a good singer
[Music]
it's like the best and the worst
[Music]
i gotta do it to i mean i think most of
chad is saying
joe a lot of william shatner
[Music]
we have a lot of stuff man we have a ton
of [ __ ]
this is crazy it's all evergreen
save it for next week yeah um
let me see if there's anything else i
need to bring up before we end it
oh god we read some donations while
you're looking over the dock
yeah uh here scrolling up
69.69 from duck six ethan
the past you've asked uh in the past
you've asked people
if they sniff their own farts i love all
my own smells farts are just the
beginning
oh i love to call in on a future after
dark to talk stank
i just have a good story about the time
that i gave myself a [ __ ]
what well that's called auto
auto fellatio i believe
some people can do it well well okay
yeah maryland two ribs taken out
uh negon o'shark donated 28
hey guys don't forget about blue beanie
remembrance day
it's coming up on this oh my goodness
the day that that one cafe in new york
stole our beanie
that's funny wow that's a throwback yeah
uh
rob shout out to my dog butto you guys
are the best shout out to butto
he donated twice twenty dollars forty
dollars for the shout out to buddha
um new age metro have you guys heard of
dan harmon's
rap about the simulation in his iced tea
voice no no i don't
dan harmon blocked me on twitter what
really
yeah what i don't know i don't remember
why
did you interact with him at some point
barely yeah
barely i responded to one of his tweets
and he blocked me
he's got a reputation for being yeah and
it's funny because i've met him once at
a rick and morty event but i don't think
he knows who i am
huh and you might know that justin and i
are friends but
huh well that's too bad he's a funny
dude yeah he's a talented guy
his stuff is great uh fifty dollar
search
oh wait whoa whoa whoa whoa throw this
up h3 out of context
just put up a james charles clip quick
h3
out of context
perfect yeah we love him we love that
man he's
the legend the legend h3 out of context
did you actually steal these designs
from teddy fresh
no july
did you actually steal these designs
from teddy fresh no
[Music]
well you know i gotta retweet that right
you know i gotta retweet that
i don't know it's on the podcast
it's a legend i mean he set himself up
from teddy fresh
he set himself up no no we gotta get
like all the no's like no
no no
[Music]
did you actually yeah that's awesome
anyway
uh anything else guys anything
else oh i have a perfect costume with
trisha
when we're recording next week how it's
even better now
maybe well guys yeah we're gonna wrap it
up now
oh there's one more person i have beef
with here who knew no more babe
yeah this guy's going
look down she's a raiding foot
foot model yeah this is ethan klein he
thinks he has some of the best feet on
youtube
sorry bro it's [ __ ] tangible
empirical evidence
and by the way um
wait so she didn't like it and by the
way you could show a better picture
not doing me any favors
i want to smell feet
[Applause]
six yeah yeah well you know what he
should have given me a better photo
mike's next and by the way
uh [ __ ] both y'all you know i'm a
[ __ ] seven out of five
next anyway seven out of five ethan
klein here
seven out of five i hope you guys have a
great weekend
please stay safe wear a mask and all
that and um
in the world
[Music]
parting wisdom would be it's always the
[ __ ] that'll get you
is that what you said it's the [ __ ]
that'll get you yeah it's always the
[ __ ] that'll get you
i'm ethan klein it's always the [ __ ]
that'll get you
all right guys we'll see you next week
love being here thank you to all of our
members who make this episode possible
thank you everyone for watching and
donating we love you we appreciate you
all
a street podcast forever we're not going
anywhere anytime soon
see you next week on monday you know how
we do it
peace peace and love
your weddings to the three three three
three you're watching
the three three three three you're
watching h to the three three three
three you're watching h two three three